Washington in the NBA the Houston
Rockets Northwestern University he says
explosiveness is back right baby
Glavine down
the pick-and-roll must feel good is up
that high
[Applause]
you've got a wagon like yours a
one-and-done trip for them Smith looking
for DeAndre the trailer it's stolen by
zach lavine you could try to catch up
that's a dunk contest guy right there
double clutch sure tie game Harry John's
and there he goes whoa he'll be against
Vernon Gomes trying to set him up
get up or get out the way oh what a boom
he's gonna put make sure her Nico man's
got his dancing shoes on and just like
Cinderella lost them food will be get up
or get out the way
[Applause]
[Music]
- fine wind out Carter jr. in the post
meet me at the rim and don't be late
[Applause]
after the poked away and he was flying
all those nice are nowhere to go
skip the claws he's gonna try to dump
that Neil and Daniel shot fake and come
fly with me
oh nice move and the control
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe that's what they need to get this
team going take just one takeoff time
flight eight Johnson though six tops so
you get yourself back with the dunk like
a dead run one dribble and then the
hammer board inviting you to visit your
local pork store Parkinson's distant
players back down to the floor seconds
and Lavine shows you why he has won that
slam dunk champion Jim a travel
here's Levine who that's off his right
leg to at least knock down a trip Archie
the active dog
[Applause]
why that was message to Phatak dunk the
to guard sack Levine says you know what
get out my way
under their broadcasters Sacramento
[Applause]
there's a nice place put the defense in
target
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Flair's big big time place this here
oh my goodness give me the hot sauce
Zach Lavine that's what a good defender
on him because that will light you guys
up but look there's a flat-out
competitor yeah I like it
okay she'll tell you that fools would
say that up to me run down I saw it
coming as well yes gets up so high
the Seattle area or can he get off the
floor to get those and be out hustle the
end of one period Zack leaving his why
in bucket there off the glass couldn't
get it to go
it has to get under control at some
point good luck here love it high flier
and watch the upstairs a different level
yes mo presided by East West Bank your
financial bridge yeah this is better
yeah it's not any lower that's for sure
the the yes mo
[Applause]
oh my goodness is gonna go meet him off
the dribble no one is there to help
that's very rare you see I was going to
say no one come and challenge that for
Boston Fox five five of to 20 sack
lemonade
slaps at home
I mean we are seeing a ballgame tonight
Levine and he pounds it down Zach Lavine
he'll throw it but he expects miles to
jump so he gets it him quickly and
that's what they totally love sure
hidden Scott was wild spit got into the
lane though couldn't caress it home
rebound
[Applause]
ridiculous highlight after how do you do
it save a play give yourself an
advantage as to get a name Lopez gets it
back to the wrong way
okay
so Robin caches at the elbow just a
simple handoff to defenders go toward
Robin everybody forgets about Levite we
give them all the signs you're all stars
now his office drop ahead let's get some
butter with them rolling a bumper car 28
left to play in the first quarter the
Bulls 14 the Pistons flow those hustles
[Applause]
who drives these Gucci store
- two reasons order the parkin and shot
clock is at seven will be to the basket
channel borders
[Music]
piss it off the glass at the sustain
anything it is nice crossover and need
to that again some pretty good defensive
player r9 427 the Bulls 5 of 17 here's a
cap as a pass
Oh down to Levine with a little bit of a
runway 37 percent movie I think all
night pick-and-roll Robyn such a great
screen get the switch cross them over
eight point news would ninety seconds
this make them have to work for
defensively that is in by Levine that's
a heck of a shot is what it is because
Wesley Matthews moved him off lines held
a thousand furloughed management or rest
in that back to back game when the Hawks
and now Levine hits a three and were
tied for making a one point Pacers lead
at eighty five eighty fool and he's come
alive in the second half he has fourteen
of his 19 in this half it's a one-point
Pacers lead
[Applause]
wake up now here and get himself going
offensive ly this transition it just
goes it right at boy trous it just
overpowers him that put that shoulder on
it we knocked him off balance and watch
right here boom right there get off me
and he goes up strong as an one seven
Zach gortak a lot of clock gets into the
lane throws it up and in off the glass
timeout Atlanta oh man nice play here
just drive to the best goal under the
arm of Lynch and he was off-balance when
he took that shot just a road block
screen from Robin Lopez got the play
going and then it was left to and then
didn't get to that sideline quicker not
Levine reporter good at Chicago lead
Zak's got 37 last interview winning
percentage of games decided by six
exterior points Levine pulls up and gets
it that's a money shot from Zach Levine
no trap there DJ went right by it big
shot by eg Lavigne again good again at
the buzzer sack Levine made three threes
in the closing minute of the first half
a few seconds left in the half Levine
rising over the top of Evan Fournier
knocking down his third three has the
assignment on the perimeter Levine turns
the corner it's good and a foul goes
right again with 333 remaining on the
clock
see Carroll's directed him trying to
direct them towards the screen but what
you need to do there is jump his right
hand so he doesn't hop was good as
master spots you here will be our please
subscribe to check out more content
because ain't nobody else making better
sports concert than us
competitions trash